now clearly this is not good enough for
a problem mathematically exploration of
this so we want a better definition so
on our big diagram over here okay
let's again experiment with something
like this put a couple of points on here
like so I've got two points I've got to
sync it right now I've got a secant
right now so let's work out what's the
gradient of this secant let's put some
coordinates on here let's suppose the
x-coordinate of this spot is anywhere so
I'm going to call the x coordinate X I'm
going to move forward some amount but
where I'm going is I want this triangle
to be really small so it's as if this
secret was like a tangent okay and then
this line is going to these points are
going to come really close together so
if I went forward a distance H it just H
is a small number here so I'm going to
move forward this way H units what will
be the x-coordinate of this spot if you
move forward H units it'll be X plus h
right so remember I'm calling its X
because it can be anywhere so I'm giving
it any any name I'm calling this
distance which I want to be a small
distance here I'm just drawing it large
so my diagram is visible H so you go
forward from X that menus okay now at
the moment what we've got is well this
is a parabola but I want to consider it
for any function right so I'm going to
call this any function right this is y
no function notation was so important to
us before at this point here I've got a
run go time
there's my run like that but I don't
have a rise how am I going to work out
right what two things what two piece of
information do I need to work out rise
yeah
yeah there we go right there and that's
why they're in our gradient formula okay
now have a look I've got enough
information to describe where these Y
coordinates are for inserts have a look
at this one here okay I'm looking for
the y coordinate
at this point I know what its
x-coordinate is I know what its
x-coordinate is so what will the
y-coordinate here be I've even written
it on the born already the y coordinate
by definition will be FX right and if at
this point my x coordinate is called x
then f of X will be the y coordinate
okay without the top one this going up
here will that be equal to this will be
yeah what your fa dress yeah see up here
right again the y coordinate is f of but
then what are you going to put in and
the answer is you'll put in your x
coordinate at this spot which is x plus
h now once you've got your 2y called
it's what you do with them you subtract
right so I've got a rod already here's
my run
what's my rise in this case it's going
to be this guy take away this guy right
that's the difference between them so
I've got that top y coordinate and then
I subtract the bottom like woman do you
agree and that's that's the rise okay so
now that I've got rice and I've got run
I can say the gradient of the secant is
equal to rise over run where's everyone
I'm going to write this he is y2 minus
y1 do you agree
and here is x2 minus x1 is that okay
that's all that means it's just the
gradient formant in fact it's so
important to emphasize that all this is
is the gradient formula I'm going to
write y2 minus y1 x2 minus x1 that's all
this is it looks fancy because I've been
using function notation but it's just
gradient that's all we working on just
like we noticed before I can simplify
the denominator like this there we go
so what is this mean well if you've got
two points they cut across your
functions like this then you can find
out its gradient easily enough just like
we did before
okay what I'm not interested in gray of
a secant
what I really want is the gray of a
tangent because then I can know what is
the Green at any particular point I can
know what's the rate of something if I
know what I'm actually comparing okay if
only I had a piece of mathematics that
allows me to take this secant and turn
it into not something that cuts the
function but something that would just
touch the function like that if only I
had a piece of mathematics that would
take this triangle and Bri need points
so close together that they were more or
less the same point
that'd be handy wouldn't it what what
you call a piece of mathematics that
could do that limits limits that's a
funny um that's a funny name how is it
going to help us okay think about this
if you took these two points if you took
these two points and you put them smack
bang on top of each other right you
grabbed him and you moved him along
what would happen to the run what would
happen to the run the run the run would
approach zero
would it not like these guys are going
to get closer and closer together what
about the rise what will happen to that
this will also come down to zero
won't it your triangle will stop being a
triangle it will start being a point
okay so you can't actually just put in H
equals zero you can't put it in you
can't evaluate it but you can work out
its limit so the grade of the seekers if
you say what happens to this gradient
when this distance here gets really
really tiny the way we say that in limit
notation is the limit as H approaches
zero right and looking at the run and
I'm trying to make it tiny so this is
the gradient of the secret you apply the
limit to the left hand side it's just
like any other mathematical operation so
I'm going to play it to the right hand
side also like this
now just pause before we move any
further that thing on the right hand
side over there some of you have already
seen this before super super important
what I want you to understand where it
comes from there are two parts to it
there's this part here and this part
here right these are the two pieces can
you remind me where this fraction comes
from what is it I wrote it in orange to
make it really clear it's just gradient
as all it is it's just write it over run
so then why why do we have this fancy
bit to it what's the point of doing that
what's the difference between um this
line and this line if you looked at the
picture right if I brought this point
over to here right
see this guideline that gradient there
that line it's going to look like this
instead right and you don't have a
secant anymore it's not cutting across
your function twice or more than twice
all it's doing is it's just touching
just touch you so in fact when you take
the limit you have the gradient not of a
secret but the gradient of that orange
line which is the tangent and that's
what this right-hand side disgusting
fraction will give us okay now one last
piece of information before we actually
start to look at it first say an example
like the one we drew earlier okay
remember we said this is a gradient
function right because it can change you
can move this point so remember we said
X can be anything you could shuffle it
around and you would get a different
gradient okay so I should use function
notation
to talk about this because the gradient
of the tangent can change right so
therefore we introduce this little piece
of notation here is a function if you
want to talk about the gradient of that
function because this is something we're
going to talk about what we want it to
be a small adjustment that sort of tells
you it's related to this but it's not
the same
so we put a little - they're not a one
it's - I read that as f dash X and the
right hand side hasn't changed f dash X
is the gradient function of f of X right
no matter what is I can define f in any
way I like